let's talk about jack first okay so we
have a friend jack butcher
who is uh he's behind this account
that's kind of
very popular on twitter called visualize
value he himself was kind of like a
designer background so very like kind of
artistic guy and um by the way
every time i say artistic i think i'm
about to say autistic and so i have to
like you know catch myself each time
make sure
i didn't call them autistic so it could
be that who knows
well actually the thing about jack is
he's very smooth very very low-key
nicest guy in the world and uh i i met
i met jack a year ago a year ago i
contacted him and asked him to do this
design
stuff and then he was just up and coming
right
and sarah and i my wife became friends
with jack and his wife
and we they spent thanksgiving with us
down here in austin where
uh they just had a baby and we've been
friends with them
talking all that stuff and he did his
story is that he used to live in new
york city
him and his wife he's british he he came
here 10 years ago
they shared a one bedroom or sorry a
studio apartment that was 400 square
feet
and he was they were nothing i mean they
were they they tried to start an agency
business it didn't go so well and they
were on their last dollar
and this was only like 18 months ago
right okay so so he
he kind of pivots to basically saying
okay within the agency
it's work that i do the part that i like
and i'm good at and other people don't
seem to like what they really want
are these like pitch decks i'm making
i'm really good at making these slides
where it's just a rectangle and i
communicate some information on it
and so that's where the visualized value
brand came from was he was just putting
out like
a little you know like an image a
rectangle that would take a concept
and like bring it to life visually and
so he started off getting popular by
just taking a bunch of naval's
popular tweets you know sayings his
little kind of one-liners
and he would create a graphic out of it
and he has this one graphic style you
if you're on twitter you've seen it it's
just black and white uh it's always a
black background with white text on top
and a
little kind of like very simplistic
minimalistic
um like graph or chart or drawing on top
of it okay so
that's visualized value so he does like
the normal creator thing he gets a
little bit of an
audience his twitter grows to a hundred
thousand people he
creates a course he creates kind of like
a paid community for people who want to
learn this thing
and he's doing well for himself right
and that's where we met everybody
and he he he's it does he does north of
a million dollars a year in revenue
and the only uh expenses
are like the small software stuff and
then him and his wife exactly
and um so he's doing he's doing very
well for himself right
but it's all relative she's doing much
better now so what happened
um this craze around nfts came out and
if you don't know what nfts is just
think of it like digital art
that people buy and uh crypto people
people really like it because it's
virtual art
in the same way that crypto is sort of
like a virtual money or a digital money
so anyways jack starts doing nfts
so jack basically takes his same art
that he's posting on twitter for free
and he's like no now you can own this
piece of art so now you can own this
post that i'm putting up
and so he just dabbles you know just
does an experiment
i don't know what the first one sold for
i think it was like one ether
right uh one when he used two two or
three thousand dollars it was like yeah
just close to two grand and uh it was
like 1.5 ether or something like that so
it's like two or three thousand bucks
still pretty sweet right like this is
just a you know dot png file that he
otherwise uploads to twitter for free
and now somebody wanted to own the dot
png file because their fans are his and
this meant
something to them and they had a bunch
of crypto gains that they could
reinvest their chucky cheese money right
and so um
okay so now he's like stepping it up so
we'll fast forward
he does some more nfts he releases
another nft this one gets
bid up and gets bought for 33 eth
which is i think something like um what
is 33e 338 times
like 70 grams like 70 grand so he sells
one of his images for 70 grand
and i called him right when i saw that i
go jack is this real did someone he goes
yeah it's crazy mate that's all i said
right right exactly because he's not
like
he's not like a schemer in any way but i
think he is smart and he is interesting
he likes to dabble
but like he wasn't he's not trying to
pull a quick one he's like
putting his art out there and people are
buying it and so i actually message the
buyer
and i go why the heck do you buy this
thing it's some random you know random
username he just goes oh you know i love
jack and i think this is going to
appreciate value and i just you know
i just really love this like i just love
the i love the art
and i was like wow okay fantastic so
that's the guy bought it for 70 grand
so then he did something even crazier
which
i'm talking about the packs do you know
the packs yeah
so to explain that one so the the part
of the story
is the the crazy there's two crazy parts
of the story the most recent thing that
happened which we'll talk
but the first crazy thing is he was like
you know what if i did
like people love jack he's got a cult
following probably more than sean people
love sho they used to love me that they
moved
and what he did was he created a website
where
you were buying a pack he had 12 packs
all it said was pack one pack two pack
three it looked like a imagine like a
baseball card but with a jack butcher
cover on it it was just black and it
said visualize value pack one
right and you would buy these packs
having no idea what the nft art was in
it right
he had 12 of them and people were
bidding on them and each one
sold for around 10 to 15 000 which is
i thought amazing till we get to the
final part of the story or at least the
most recent part of the story
exactly so he so he gets to today i log
on to twitter as i do
first thing in the morning uh what's
going on in the world tonight holy [__]
jack butcher has listed a new piece of
art for 76 million dollars
something like that what is this what's
the exact number 72 76 million
he basically and it's called fame and
what he did was
the most the highest um priced nft
thus far in the history of mankind was
beeple
the the artist people uh who's like jack
but even
more popular so people had done a a few
drops
those drops were like kind of in the one
to five million range-ish
and then the most popular nft of all
time was sold for 69 million dollars
recently
and like there's some rumors that like
that was sort of a manufactured sale
like somebody came in and did it just to
like
they're gonna like i don't know these
are rumors but rumors were that they
kind of made it a publicity stunt
so anyways jack uh basically says cool
this is a nft called fame and for fame
is it it'll be the number one priced
uh piece of artwork in a digital artwork
in the world right so he prices it above
the
people i wasn't i wasn't referring to
this i was referring to what he did last
i didn't even see this this is crazy
today last
last week what he did was he he wrote
he did an nft and it says here's the
difference between a uh
a jpeg and an nft and it just had a
verified it
he basically made a tweet and then he
sold that tweet for like
150 000 right which i thought was crazy
this is way crazier yeah because
it's crazier because it might work
exactly so okay so
let's walk through this if you're jack
why i'll tell you why do this and why it
might actually work why do this well
um if if nothing else this is just a
great way to
drive attention uh press and um
and just do something that's bold right
so pricing you know pricing a piece of
your artwork for 77 million dollars it
doesn't even mean
it doesn't even matter if somebody buys
it just pricing it for 77 million
dollars
is uh is already going to put you on the
map the second thing is
this might be a you know let's say you
take the three outcomes
somebody actually buys it for 77 million
dollars right
um there's been crypto punks now the the
number one crypto punk
sold for oh bro you look this up how
much did that crypt the top crypto punk
sell for
i think it was like seven seven million
dollars something like that
people sold for 69 million so there is a
chance there is a maybe
five percent two percent chance that
this thing actually sells for 77 million
dollars which would be
incredible second thing this might be a
shoot for the stars you land on the moon
situation
uh yeah the crypto poke sold for seven
and a half million um
and the guy who bought it by the way
this is kind of cool i don't know how
you pronounce this but
the person who bought it his handle is
perugia or pervugias i don't know what
it is i'm not
in the art world but that's the same
that's an homage basically that's the
same name of the guy who stole the mona
lisa
which is what helped catapult the mona
lisa to fame was when it was stolen
um and that was like part of the part of
what made the mona lisa even more
remarkable and
more valuable now most valuable piece of
artwork in the world
um and so so okay so by the way
great usage of the word homage yeah
thank you
um we're trying to class it up right
here so all right so so he might not
sell it for 77 million but even if it
sells for 1.7 million that's 1.7 million
dollars that he just
you know manufactured through his own
creativity and you know and probably
i would bet you like four days of effort
um i got
i have chills looking at this tweet that
he put out the reason why this is so
crazy is
it might work someone might be crazy
enough to do this
right he basically has a no loss
situation and because jack's brand
is because he is authentic he is
um not kind of like a you know
quick flash in the pan trying to make a
quick quick dollar like he's literally
almost like
he's more of an artist really than he is
like anything else and so he's been
doing this for a while he's been
creating daily content he's been
building up a following and
so just like people did that people did
people did a new piece of art every day
for 10 years
and so it's like you know he's an
overnight success 10 years in the making
and i think jack's very similar so
i see jack having a no lose situation
and this is
nfts are a thing that basically fits his
skill set and so like there's a lot of
reasons people kind of
[__] on nfts right now one is that it's
overvalued it's a bubble what do you
really own look i can just screenshot
and boom i own the thing too
you know like there's a bunch of ways
you can make fun of this but one of the
good things that came out of this is
that
um you know in most of these these like
kind of hype cycles
it's the suits on wall street that get
rich uh this time at least it's starving
artists that get rich and so
you know at the very worst even if the
whole thing comes crashing now at least
a few artists got paid
and you know who could be really too mad
at that i i can't so
so i think this is kind of like an
amazing thing jack's doing this boggles
my mind should we ask him to come on do
you want jack to come on yeah we should
be sure
are you friends with him yeah all right
not as close as you guys but yeah
we're close you should mess with him
let's see if he hops on today
um just be like you free to come talk
about your
thing for for five minutes let's see if
he hops on at the end of this
all right i just texted him all right
we'll we'll come we'll come back to that
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back